your husband's here Jason who I really
like very I love that guy I met him a
couple times and he is from I think I've
talking about once and he mentioned he's
from Virginia that's right
did his his kinfolk do they come - yeah
yeah they eat vittles and they're called
kinfolk they come here to LA mo he
actually just had a fun visit with his
brother Todd and their two sons their
two sons him in his wife Emily and I
have to say the names yeah yeah we do um
their sons Emmett and John Lewis we had
a great visit we showed him all around
LA went to a Dodgers game we went to
Disneyland which was really fun um we
they've never been to like a theme park
before and you've never been to a theme
park and your first crack at one is
Disneyland that's pretty sweet yeah
right um we took so john lewis had never
been on a rollercoaster how will you go
he's four for ya he's like a little he's
like a little whippersnapper yeah that
was a really good impression of him you
don't know that you haven't met him nope
impression of him and any gold miner but
we took him on the first rail rail nope
it's not called railroad what is it
called rollercoaster rollercoaster was
the the Thunder Mountain Railroad that's
where that happened and when we were
done he was just sort of like a
wide-eyed and excited and we were like
how did you like it Johnny listen he was
like that rollercoaster made my penis
tickle
it happened that would be yeah really
good
that's a good description of what it
feels like yeah it is I chose but it's
also like for a kid to be yelling that
you know and if he says it wrong like I
just got my penis tickled on every note
I mean on a ride it's just a lot of red
flag yeah yeah yeah no but he I mean
that that was sort of like our barometer
for the rest of the day is like well how
much did that make your penis tickle leg
made my penis
now you're talking my life do you visit
these people in the family in Virginia
do you ever go to Virginia yeah we go to
the week yeah we visit the cartoons all
the time we often go for holidays yeah
and let's see the last time we went I
it's I don't know do you get sick during
the holidays I always get sick during
yes yeah I always get sick in the
holidays because I get stressed out
before the holiday it lowers my immune
system then I get on a plane with people
coughing and whoa are you a doctor what
are you a doctor what are you talking on
they're really smart yeah Wow you go to
some dumb doctors
immune system I'm blown away Wow
and then I hurt my arm but the last time
I was there I did I was so sick once I
got there that I went straight to the
emergency room and people in Virginia
are so charming and lovely and I being a
California girl and like so charms by a
southern a southern accent is the most
amazing so adorable and charming and you
fall in love and and I so anyway I was
coughing a lot and I went to the
emergency room and this sort of like big
strapping male nurse was taking x-rays
of my chest
mm-hmm and while he was taking these
lungs lungs anyway while he was taking
you sure he worked for the hot ma'am I'm
gonna take some pictures of you yes well
thank you I'm gonna go now who was that
I often go into hospitals of the campus
here to take a picture all right I
this guy was taking x-rays and he he
asked he said for he was like what do
you do for a living and I said I was an
actor and he was like do you do any
manual labor and I said no and he goes
I've just never seen a spine like that
on a woman what that's right he said
that to me he said so you have the spine
of a man that he's done a lot of
back-breaking manual labor
and I and my reaction was like what does
that mean tell me tell me tell me what
do you mean exploit yourself and he was
just kind of like oh shucks I gotta go
yeah he said it's very rough but he
wasn't like insulting me he was kind of
like it is what it is darling well have
you had your spine checked out and
anymore you hear doctor right well I am
fine I know arm and immune system so yes
I am no I haven't had my spine shot I
mean I guess the next time I go to a
doctor I should be like hey yeah what
what's up with my spine and you'll say I
don't know when there's a spine ever
been described as rough rough
again I'm not a doctor but I guess and
again you were not in a hospital